this budget was supposed to be about
taking Britain forward overcame economic
waters instead it's gonna be all about
this the black hole in the chancellor's
accounts for the past eight years
Britain's public finances have looked a
little bit like this a vast vortex at
the heart of governments sucking money
out of its coffers now George Osborne
was rather hoping that this was going to
dry up and he'd be left with a healthy
balance sheet just why he devised
himself too hard fiscal rules the first
is that the national debt must fall
every year as a percentage of GDP the
second is the government needs to have a
surplus in other words to collect more
tax each year than it spends by 2019-20
but with the economy weakening the
boffins working here at the Treasury are
going to find it far more difficult to
meet those rules than back in the autumn
first the national debt might actually
still be rising his pledge to cut debt
as a share of our economy every year
going forwards and in principle there
are good reasons to want to do that but
in practice he's been aiming to do it
really judge driven because of his
selling off of assets and that's pretty
much cheating the spirit of that rule
and it now looks like some of those
asset sales won't go ahead and if that's
the case he might end up breaking the
actual practice of the rule as well as
the spirit of it second the surface rule
doesn't look quite so easy according to
the man who actually helped write it
until last year Rupert howson worked
here as the Chancellor's chief of staff
he's given himself a little bit of
wiggle room to start with albeit 10
billion pounds in five years time is not
that much in terms of what he can do to
achieve that you know there are no
there's no third way in a way the seds
either you're going to put up taxis or
you're going to cut spending and I think
that say you know in the budget and the
Autumn Statement since the election
there's been a bit of both I would
expect that to continue to understand
why consider what's happening here in
Sheffield for centuries this is where
the world came for steel today these
mills are under permanent threat in the
face of Chinese competition and
collapsing metal prices this is pretty
much smack bang in the middle of the
Chancellor's northern powerhouse halfway
between Sheffield and Manchester and
every way look there are reminders of
what used to make Britain great
got the steel mills the industrial
heartlands this reservoir was actually
used by the dam Busters for their
practice flights but for all of the talk
the economy here is still struggling and
wages are still stagnant weak wages mean
weak tax revenues falling share prices
mean falling capital gains tax and with
the EU referendum on the horizon the
Chancellor is desperate not to do
anything to alienate voters this week so
his hands are tied this was supposed to
be a bold budget about reshaping Britain
instead it's likely to be dominated by
worries about money still escaping down
the plughole Eddie Conway Sky News